-It is end of the week
and that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and of course,
send out thank you notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
And I wondered if I could
write out
my thank you notes right now.
Hopefully --
[ Enthusiastic
cheers and applause ]
Uhh...oh.
I should have...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Thank you. I should have --
[ Drum beating ]
I should have done this earlier
in the monologue.
[ Laughter ]
James, can I get something?
I don't know.
Just noodle on the ivories.
[ Laughter ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
-That was your third record,
right?
[ Laughter ]
"Noodlin' On the Ivories,"
with the apostrophe.
Alright, here we go.
Going to write out
some thank you notes.
[ Smacks lips ]
♪♪
Thank you,
the Trump boat parade,
for being the first parade
that replaced all the floats
with sinks.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Trump tell-all books,
for being the "Fast and Furious"
movies of the publishing world.
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ Movie announcer voice ]
From the makers...
♪♪
[ Normal voice ] Thank you,
Martha Stewart's new CBD line,
for really adding confusion
to the sentence,
"My mom loves to bake."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, pullout couches.
You may be uncomfortable
couches,
but at least you're
also uncomfortable beds.
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ New Yorker accent ] There's
a bar in the back of that.
There's a bar in the mattress.
♪♪
[ Normal voice ]
Thank you, Dairy Queen,
for releasing Blizzard-scented
candles
and somehow not being
the first time
I've been tempted
to eat a candle.
[ Chuckles ]
-Come on.
-Yes.
-Those Yankee cand--
They smell so good.
-Hey, man.
-That's what I'm talking about
right here.
-You have one?
-Mm-hmm.
-Nice.
-That looks like the candle
Ebenezer Scrooge, like --
[ Laughter ]
-No, this is what they sell
in Yankee Candle.
-Okay.
-Stuff like that,
the candle place.
A modern candle
with candle drippings.
This is not a cake.
-It's real Dickensian, like...
-You need a harpsichord.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-Wait, what?!
[ Harpsichord playing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Not bad.
-Wow.
-That was harder than I thought.
I thought it totally was --
-Wait, what just happened?
-I was told it was a cake.
I thought it was a cupcake.
It's like a chocolate bar.
-That was a cup.
-God.
That wasn't even a cupcake.
That was a cup.
-That was a cup.
[ Laughter ]
-I just ate porcelain.
You don't see -- You can go
into a Yankee candle,
you see these candles
all over --
Bath and Body -- everything.
[ Laughter ]
It's almost like a Halloween
decoration kind of.
Which, by the way, I just got
those pumpkins that move.
Did you see those things?
-No.
-It's a pumpkin.
Man, they know how to do it
on Instagram.
They give these ads, all of
my ads are for these pumpkins.
How do they know I want these?
I bought it.
-And you got one.
-It worked. Absolutely.
The pumpkins,
they have a projector
in the plastic pumpkin and they
make the mouths move
and they talk and they sing
and stuff.
And I totally got suckered
into doing it.
-Yeah.
-You have them up already?
-I ordered them just in case.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, they're up already.
-Sold out.
[ Laughter ]
It's Halloween year-round
in my house.
[ Chuckles ] Here we go.
♪♪
Thank you, men named Todd,
for making me imagine
a baby named Todd.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
I mean, it is solid --
-What flavor is that, yo?
-I was told this was a cupcake.
This is --
Look at this thing, man.
[ Laughter ]
This is like actually eating
a real candle. I should have
just ate a real candle.
Is it a real candle?
-No.
-Got him.
[ Laughter ]
-I just ate an actual candle.
[ Scoffs ]
I think it is.
-Oh, man.
-God.
-Are you okay?
-No.
This is like I just ate wax.
-You're not going to be
the same.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh my gosh.
♪♪
Thank you, plates,
for being high-stakes Frisbees.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank you notes.
-Don't eat a plate.